♪ ♪
>> Dagen: SURPRISE, SURPRISE.
BORDERS ARE KAMALA HARRIS STILL
NOT TAKING THE CRISIS SERIOUSLY.
VICE PRESIDENT SPEAKING UP BIG
MEETING MEXICO WITH SECRETARIES
MAYORKAS AND BLINK.
SHE WAS IN NEW JERSEY VISITING A
DAY CARE CENTER AND STOPPED BY A
BAKERY AND SHE HAD TIME FOR
THIS.
SPACE VIDEO FOR KIDS WHICH
CRITICS ARE CALLING
CRINGEWORTHY.
>> I LOVE THE IDEA OF EXPLORING
THE UNKNOWN.
YOU'RE GOING TO LITERALLY SEE
THE CRATERS ON THE MOON WITH
YOUR OWN EYES.
WE WANT YOU TO REALLY REMEMBER
THIS.
NEVER LET ANYBODY TELL YOU WHO
YOU ARE.
YOU TELL THEM WHO YOU ARE.
YOU'VE GOT THAT?
I HAVE MORE ADVICE.
[LAUGHS]
>> Dagen: [LAUGHS]
GREG.
>> Greg: .
>> Greg: LIKE A CHEERLEADER ON
PSILOCYBIN.
WEIRD, BUBBLY, YOU DON'T KNOW
WHY.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT SHE'S WORSE
WITH CHILDREN THAN I AM.
SHE SHOULD TAKE A PAGE OUT OF MY
BOOK.
DON'T INTERACT --
THEY ASK YOU TO DO IT, DON'T DO
IT.
SHE'S FAKE.
SHE'S SUPER FAKE.
SHE WAS THE ONE WHO CALLED
JOE BIDEN THE WORST THING YOU
COULD EVER CALL SOMEBODY THESE
DAYS WHICH IS RACIST AND SHE WAS
ASKED ABOUT IT AGAIN WHEN SHE
BECAME VP AND SHE LAUGHED.
IT WAS THE DEBATE.
CALLING SOMEBODY A RACIST
KNOWING THAT IT'S NOT TRUE,
THAT'S PRETTY BAD BUT I
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY HAVE HER
TALK ABOUT THE MOON.
THEY WANT HER AS FAR AWAY FROM
ANY OTHER PRACTICAL ISSUES.
>> Dana: NEXT WEEK SHE'LL BE
ON BLUE ORIGINS WITH WILLIAM
SHATNER.
>> Greg: SHE SHOULD BE.
SLEEP THAT THEY GET HER AWAY
FROM WHAT SHE IS SUPPOSED TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR, THE BORDER
CRISIS, BUT THEN THEY DO THIS.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING, I DON'T UNDERSTAND
IT.
I REALLY THINK HER INSTINCT SEEM
TO BE REALLY OFF.
IF YOU FOLLOWED HER SENATE
CAREER, SHE NEVER ACTUALLY
PASSED A BILL.
SHE SHOWED UP AT EVERY PRESS
CONFERENCE TO TALK ABOUT THE
BILLS THAT HAD PASSED.
THE ROOT CAUSES OF THE
IMMIGRATION DEBACLE, THEY ARE
NOT GOING TO BE SOLVED IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION WERE SHE COULD
GIVE A PRESS RELEASE.
SHE HAD THE GAFFE WHERE SHE
LAUGHED ABOUT GOING TO THE
BORDER.
THE NEXT DAY PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAID NOW YOU'RE IN CHARGE OF THE
BORDER.
FIVE DAYS LATER, THEY WERE LIKE
NELL.
JUST THE ROOT CAUSES OF THE
BORDER.
HERE'S A PERSON WHO ACHIEVED AN
INCREDIBLE ACCOMPLISHMENT.
SHE'S THE FIRST WOMAN
VICE PRESIDENT IN OUR COUNTRY.
AMAZING ACCOMPLISHMENT.
COMES WITH A LOT OF POWER THAT A
LOT OF PRESTIGE AND SHE DOESN'T
USE ANY OF IT AND IT DRIVES ME
CRAZY.
IF I WERE IN HER POSITION, I
NEVER WOULD'VE LET THOSE THREE
GUYS GO DOWN TO MEXICO WITHOUT
ME.
I WOULD'VE SAID YOU CAN FLY WITH
ME AND BRIEFED ME ALONG THE WAY
AND THEN WILL WALK IN TOGETHER
AS A TEAM AND I WILL BE THE ONE
TO SPEAK.
TAKE CHARGE OF IT.
INSTEAD.
IT'S PERFECTLY FINE TO TALK
ABOUT SPACE WITH KIDS.
IT'S GREAT BUT YOU THINK ABOUT
THE ENORMITY OF THE POWER SHE
HAS IN THE CAPACITY AND THE
CAPABILITIES TO COME WITH THE
OFFENSE AND SHE IS NOT UTILIZING
IT, DRIVES ME NUTS.
>> Jesse: AT LEAST SHE DIDN'T
SNIFF THE KIDS HAIR.
THAT'S SOMETHING TO BE THANKFUL
FOR.
SHE DOESN'T LOVE PEOPLE WHO
EXPLORE THE UNKNOWN.
SHE IS ANTI-COLUMBUS.
THE BEST EXPLORER WE'VE SEEN.
THERE'S TWO SCENARIOS.
ONE, SHE HAS THE IMMIGRATION
THING REMOVED FROM HER PORTFOLIO
BECAUSE THE LAST TIME SHE WENT
THERE SHE BROUGHT NOTHING BACK
AND BORDER CROSSINGS EXPLODED,
OR SHE HERSELF REMOVED
IMMIGRATION FROM HER OWN
PORTFOLIO.
NOW JOE BIDEN IS SENDING PRETTY
MUCH THE WHOLE CABINET THERE.
BIDEN IS RUNNING OUT OF TIME.
HE CAN'T KEEP SENDING EVERYBODY
DOWN SOUTH TO DEAL WITH
IMMIGRATION.
EVENTUALLY IT COMES TO JOE.
JOE HAS NEVER BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
IT'S ONLY BEEN NINE MONTHS AND
HE HAS ALREADY DEPUTIZED FIVE
PEOPLE TO GO FIX THE PROBLEM?
20% APPROVAL ON THE BORDER.
HE IS GOING TO HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING EXECUTIVE ACTION OR
ADMINISTRATIVELY TO REPEL PEOPLE
FROM CROSSING INTO THE COUNTRY
INSTEAD OF ABSORBING THEM.
>> Dagen: YOU KNOW HOW I KNOW
THIS IS A BIG PROBLEM.
HILLARY CLINTON CAME OUT TODAY
AND SAID SHE WILL NEVER BE OUT
OF THE GAME OF POLITICS.
SHE SEES PRESIDENT STUMBLE BUS.
SHE SAYS SHE'S NOT GOING TO RUN
FOR ANYTHING THAT WE KNOW THAT
MIGHT NOT BE TRUE.
>> Harold: I SAID THAT
SECRETARY'S MAYORKAS IS PROBABLY
A GOOD GUY BUT HE'S NOT A MAN
YOU WANT WHEN A CRISIS IS
UNDERWAY.
I WOULD THINK DIFFERENTLY ABOUT
THAT.
MAYBE IT'S BEST NOT TO BE ON
THAT PLANE.
DEMOCRATS NEED TO BUILD A WALL.
REPUBLICANS, INVEST IN THE
HEMISPHERE.
DEMOCRATS, IT'S IMPORTANT WE
SEND MORE JUDGES.
MORE JUDGES TO THE COURTS TO
EXPEDITE THIS STUFF AT THE
BORDER.
REPUBLICANS, GETTING DREAMERS
BILL.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY WE GET TO A
PATH TO CITIZENSHIP WHICH IS
WHAT YOU TRYING TO GET TO UNDER
PRESIDENT BUSH.
PRESIDENT BIDEN DOESN'T SEEM TO
HAVE A POLICY.
TO YOUR POINT IT DOES COME BACK
TO HIM.
AS MUCH AS I WANT TO BLAME SOME
OF THE OTHERS, IF YOU DON'T HAVE
A POLICY FOR THEM TO EXECUTE,
IT'S HARD TO FULLY BLAME THEM.
AS TO HOW THEY ARE MANAGING IT.
WE NEED A POLICY.
IF NOT, POLLING DATA SHOWS THIS
BORDER CRISIS BOTCH IS A HUGE
PART OF WHY THESE NUMBERS ARE
WHERE THEY ARE.
THE 2022 ELECTION IN 2024
ELECTION WILL DEPEND A LOT ON
HOW WE DEAL WITH THIS GOING
FORWARD.
>> Dagen: SHE WILL BE
REMEMBERED.
TH